another computer stopped working for
some gnomes loose in our computer system
it's both hardware and software
the original SSD or it's this new one we
put in it's being janky and it's both
network and local so this computer's not
working either
no which doesn't narrow down anything we
had Spencer come over he took a look at
it is this April Fool's and you didn't
tell me we never have an issue with a
computer that's built here any computer
built elsewhere plenty of from small
projects tried and then below that is a
Mac Drive ESS their FS days I leave the
Matt grubs in this to see isn't it might
be I know the one that's beneath that's
a oh yeah the my drive is on messes T ok
it's happening right let me go huh so
and we really learned what makes an
interesting scene I really love the
production quality of Assassin's Creed
for shooting our pirate ship was great I
loved working with all those actors and
I'm in my opinion the movie itself is
pretty rough like watching it now I'm
like why do we have this whole intro at
like the pirate tavern like who cares
let's get to the ship all this really
like an obfuscated drama you promise me
two thousand pounds well you're making
it four thousand pounds and it's like
who who cares who knows what that is
what's where's the value one of the
glasses we learned from that you can
give people numbers but they don't
really matter you need to give them the
why you told me one thing but you're
changing the deal on me and that's
pissing me off you [ __ ] liar well too
bad because I'm in control
oh like you need to say that you're in a
modern movie like somebody breaks
through banks like we're gonna steal a
billion dollars it's like well it's a
lot of money I'm gonna get a 97 70
digital decoder with 71 amps and burr
brown the ACS I mean well you can really
just say is we're gonna be rich beyond
our wildest dreams it's big stereo
speakers so loud they blow women's
clothes off now you'll like that's so
much more valuable one thing you can
throw in the details here and there and
even then there's nuances to how you go
out doing that it is less we learned
from assassin's creed 4 black sails
someone's been sending packages to Sam
Gore she free sins core
from Manitoba Canada and last time they
sent it to him a butterfly legitimately
flew out of the package I don't know if
these guys are like casting spells I'm
gonna open this this way in case it's
got like a dove in it or something
they always send them to Sam so what is
the so it's Walking Dead coloring book
coloring book so I think that they
published these although they never
actually have ever explained what they
do they like found our address and they
just send us like a new thing every
month thanks guys at free since Walking
Dead coloring book
I've tried eating the power button and
it doesn't seem to boot we lost about
three hours of work time because of that
so we were scrambling to get out and
export I'll talk to Sam and try to get a
laptop hooked up to the mic so we can
only skip that before the day is over
you're not able to do any substance I'm
able to do sound design yes but a big
chunk of what I need to get done still
needs to be recorded for me to move
forward so it's 4:35 right now we can't
get this working by 5:00 we'll just do a
laptop we tried some BIOS settings see
if it's a BIOS setting or not was trying
to boot from a second Drive got rid of
those unplugged those still not wanting
to boot try doing the repair everything
we seem to do just either fails or stops
said did you try booting into safe mode
didn't wasn't Ruby giving us trouble -
John was also working on visual effects
and his computer was having trouble
starting as well it's a how are you
working back alright so our temp
workaround solution for this is that
I've just been unplugging my PC box and
carrying it back and forth from my desk
to the back room seems to be working
fine for now yeah and then Carmichael's
computer got blue screened all on the
same day when this project was due so
again likely reliable evidence leads us
to believe that there are tiny gnomes
that have infiltrated the hardware and
we are so far unsuccessful at locating
them
Drunken like there was a point where I
think we were all like somehow on the
floor wrestling in the hallway oh dude
you guys got a one meal holy [ __ ]